do you have do you have money to invest
no any money at all
no so what what are you how are you
okay so you're you're deal sourcing to
live yeah i mean the deals that i'm
selling
is one a month but i'm co-deal sourcing
that as well
okay so i'm making half of the this the
sale so yeah
it's 1500 quid for for one for one deal
yeah but
you know i'm keeping made up of water
that's okay my main goal
at the minute you know since got me
redundant and needed to find a way to
replace that wage yeah pay for
my house pay for my living where are you
at financially right now
like are you in a decent place
financially
john truth of course and no
i'm not i'm not in a good place and
since i've got maybe running obviously
i've been trying to do these i've been
selling these deals one every month
keeping me above water but financially
no
i'm not in a good place with it
when saying not in a good place like
have you got if you've got debts or
yeah yeah you know i do have debts
i've got you know a thousand pound
overdraft
there's a credit card debt as well so
that's like three and a half grand
when do you need to pay that bar do you
know
if i'm honest it's pretty soon because
they're chasing
okay like they're asking for your
address and confirming it it causes
unnecessary stress
on you know on on rachel as well and
like for me it's just always it's always
there
but i try so hard to push it to the back
you know
because i know i've still got you know
i've still got to get out there and find
deals just to keep this just to my food
which i mean
yeah support my son so at a minute like
i didn't think i'd do that you know yeah
i think it makes me realize it like when
i say about mason
you know because you want to support him
yeah
so we need four and a half grand to be
able to tear this
up and and be debt free
so we've got a viewing today first
viewing launch launched
what situation with this this is a
rental rams yeah
potential events event yeah i mean we've
put the view in
uh told the agent that it's somewhere
where i'm looking to live
that's a bad move bro i know but my
thought behind it is that we couldn't
get in anywhere yesterday
and i'm just excited to view a property
and just spend some time with an agent
okay okay well let's see what happens
you can do the talking because i think
this is
a bit awkward
it's nice it's a big space
so with like rentals like this
do you do you watch with corporate lands
so in terms of like dealing with
landlords and doing like long
long term legs no
but it isn't after i'm trying to find
like flats are great as well mainly look
for houses
and we're trying to work with landlords
on like a long term let and
i don't know if that's something that
you you guys do with your place
you're so blessed then really do you
it's not it's not so that it's a company
yeah you've put work cut people yeah
things like that
it's not something we do at the moment
now no
what's it like for reading at a minute
are you really busy with it
really this year is it what about the
houses around salford because they're
sort of like the ones i'm really really
interested in as well
yeah yeah no i'm interested in this one
as well yeah
for a rental for yourself yes but i'm
also interested in other properties as
well
but you won't be able to rent this and
then let it out to other people no
no i'm interested in this one for myself
how do you think that went really bad
the manchester agents don't
like renting the rent it's gonna keep
ringing
when you ring they don't answer when you
go in
they're rude and there was me thinking
manchester would be a friendly place
i did think that would probably be a bit
further than where we are already that
just seems like they won't even let us
in the door well
they won't even be like i couldn't have
a look around the property or exactly
but i thought london would be like this
and manchester will be easier yeah yeah
but it really isn't so what do you want
to do
no i don't know mate i just think
i just thought i just don't even see how
the whole thing's gonna
even see how the whole thing's gonna go
i just don't
yeah well we're still
you know we're not even halfway through
yet
but two days in i thought we'd get more
done
it's just really really hard with the
whole culvert the national lockdown
we can't get in agents can't even get
viewings we're just like
banging our head against the wall all
the time yeah
no i didn't feel
so what do you want to do
i don't know
i'm not sure mate i'm not sure
i want to i just feel like he's um
he's just not he just don't want to
carry on doing this
this is probably the hardest um hardest
one i've done man
turn the camera
listen i was in debt man i i have
problems okay
now you can worry about that but when
you worry about stuff you just manifest
it it just broke so what's the point
why don't we focus on the stuff that
actually generates money not costs money
okay so like all the bad debt all that
[ __ ] it off don't worry about it i'm not
saying ignore it i'm just saying stop
stressing about it yeah cause what's the
worst
that happened the absolute worst is
gonna happen
did they turn up at the door they're not
allowed to not do it
[Laughter]
yeah that's it
life-changing literally life-changing
from the ground up
don't be serious
because i'll be as hard as you want me
to be
because that's how i am i well we've got
two deals man
if we sell these two deals he's
completely out of debt
speak to speak some investors send me
the deals i'll send them out to my
mailing list now
oh i did we'll crack on with it right
now yeah when
arsdale was talking you looked a little
bit emotional at one point what was
happening what were we thinking
i don't know i think like the whole
experience is emotional
i mean it's hard work you know we
constantly
got this like pressure on like i feel
like there's constant pressure
throughout this
to start this challenge and i feel like
you know
even when somebody says like god you
know you just need to
suck it up and just carry on it's like
sometimes you just need to hear those
words you've got to remember like
most people don't even talk about dexter
i mean yeah i don't think i ever spoke
about it as much to anybody except for
you
yeah so i mean like i won't sell anybody
i won't sell
family members i don't want anybody to
know when you're made redundant did you
have savings
no okay never i've never had savings
so you just kind of used to have your
money coming from your job and then you
spend it yeah
and then you got mind redundant and then
it was like whoa
gone it was like that that platform that
you stood upon all the time had just
been like pulled
so you lost the house is that really
gonna ruin your life
i mean no but i don't want mason to see
it
yeah so that's the fear yeah like i just
don't want him to see like
he doesn't he even he didn't know
i got married obviously not to tell you
a kid but like it took him a while for
him to turn out to be and say
how did you still work at that company
i'm like no no daddy set his own company
up now
daddy's got his own business so i mean
so like
he he never knew this is like my moment
yeah
you know there's no other time and i
kind of used the lockdown
you know the bad situation of the
lockdown to my advantage because i was
like
there's no other time to learn something
i was gonna come out of lockdown with a
brand new skill
and i swore that to myself as soon as i
got off that call i got onto your three
six five
and a four because how long was the
first slot down like four weeks yeah
i was like i'm gonna come out of this a
brand new person and then that was
literally the start of the whole
property stuff this is my phone
i've got a message from alistair saying
any luck
and this is your phone
people wanting to buy the deals off you
wow
thanks matt
[Music]
i don't know
and they're not saying i'm interested
they're saying i want to reserve it
so one of them just put one onto how you
feeling
just overwhelmed
i've never cried to a watcher
can i give you a gift congratulations
[Music]
did you ever look at the um the outside
of it and everything
yeah yeah it looks really good like it
like like as samuel mentioned like
it's one of those properties where an
older couple have been there it's
you know the grass is like cut with
scissors you know what i mean it's like
really it's really nice where do you
live where do you live jimmy
um london are you a bit far out i was
gonna say if you're around
you know once you've once you've secured
this particular property if you're
around
you could even come down and we could
meet up and stuff and we can show you
some of the other projects we're working
on
um but it just depends if you can get
here
oh [ __ ] oh man
i just had someone crash into me hold on
oh man
where did the where did the driver go i
don't even know
he just smashed into the back of me
didn't i was he he just got off
oh my goodness did you see
did you see the guy that i didn't see
anything i felt it and then by the time
it was pulled off
i just assumed that it stopped next to
us but he's not
[Applause]
oh jeez that's the last thing you want
on a freaking wet wednesday morning well
look i don't know what we can do if the
guy's not around
i'm just gonna have to call my insurance
and tell me what happened but
[ __ ] you hurt it really fits a bit oh
let's go
let's go as we crash the car and come
into the house
the house we have to buy it now
it's just pure cash watch the hmo
investment isn't it you know what i like
about this property though a lot
i like that it's off market i like that
it would rent out really waste in a
really good area there is a lot to do
95 grand for this isn't a bargain no
it's not
but it's gonna give a great return on
investment yeah
i definitely think that you could sell
this
what do you think about that last house
i thought it was really good thank you
so much for showing us around
are you welcome that property that we
just looked at needs a lot of work if it
was in good
condition how well do you think it would
rent out as a hmr i think it would go
pretty much straight away
do that yeah i think it's a good area
yeah both for students and for
professionals as well it's awesome
well let's um see if we can find an
investor for right yeah um and see what
we can do but we'll give you a call back
yeah thank you so much for your time as
well really appreciate it on to the next
viewing
we're in the middle of a pandemic
everything's closed
we just had a car crash but nothing's
gonna stop us can't stop won't stop
right let's go this one is good
this one this one's really big as well
actually
this is probably one of the biggest ones
the women's like a really shoot in the
area
so hmos obviously really work well there
so you'd manage this yourself
since this is like a brr hmr yeah i hate
smoke yeah definitely
so this move looks like it's probably
one of the smaller ones
but you know what actually it probably
just looks more because these cupboards
are all built out this is the actual
wall
so what we need to do is we need to
measure it really
just so that we know
2.7 this is big
by 2.9 plenty so this room's fine plenty
just this just was taken out so you're
going to get three rooms up here
one room downstairs four room hmo yeah
it's on the market for 125.
yeah the agent said that except hundred
and ten
once have we lifted it up i reckon it'd
be worth about 140.
yeah definitely so what's let's just got
some great stairs
so this room is going to be so you've
got 300 upstairs this room
is basically just going to be a a a
bedroom yeah
and then kitchen through here yeah work
it's got enough forward and get it
wrapped up
yeah good job that's dude good fine so
basically you know that property we've
just seen that hmo yeah i sold it
no three and a half grand hang on that
isn't
that isn't the bungalow no the one that
we've just been to this morning
i sold it who did you sell it to it's an
investor i've been speaking to for the
past couple of days and i was telling
him
as soon as i found out about the
opportunity i booked it in to see it
this morning on purpose
hang on a minute though we've also
almost sold the bungalow
yeah so when that sold that would be
seven grand
and then we still got the middles we
want to do so we're gonna we're gonna
you're gonna you're pretty much
debt-free now bro
that's great let's keep wrapping things
up and keep getting more
yeah that's what i'm gonna relax no no
no no no we're not brand i don't wanna
celebrate too much that we don't yeah
done just got a text on the phone seven
bags in the bank
oh no nice job
that's all for them done both of them
sold straight away why don't you just
pay off your debt now then
that's good isn't it it is how do you
feel that
buzzing like absolutely made up like i
don't think it's really hit me
do i mean yeah like it's just like a
number in the account i'm just like
it'll take some time no never never
you've never never never seen so many
zeros
that's what we can add to it yeah